je savais qu'on soutient les héros des
hôpitaux tous les joueurs dans toute la
france en leur délivrant des repas avec
des livres ou et ce soir on est en
direct de strasbourg à la clinique
sainte barbe
on connait vraiment aller là bas quand
on sait que la région du grand est resté
particulièrement touchés par l'épidémie
merci à au personnel hospitalier de
sainte barbe d'être avec nous ce soir et
de prendre quelques secondes pour nous
faire un coucou
merci à vous est-ce que ça va bien les
cherry est ce qu'on vous en sortez oui
merci d'être là merci d'être là c'est
bon et franchement merci d merci d'être
aussi souriante merci d'être là on vous
a envoyé quelques repas on vous en voyez
donc un grand merci à burger de papa à
213 heat avait les choses burger et à
ramen shop regardez vous envoyer une
petite livraison
voilà pour vous faire si ferme pas trop
compter qu'à vous faites un travail
exceptionnel de travailler toute la
journée c'est justement là notre petit
titre petite contribution pour voilà
pour vous faire un petit qui voilà c'est
tout et on voulait vous faire un petit
coucou et vous dire qu'on est avec vous
à fond que toute la france est avec vous
et qu'on vous aime fort merci prenez
soin de vous en tout cas et on a besoin
de vous et voilà et je vous le dis et
j'espère qu'après moi je vous le dit
j'espère que quand il y aura moins de
monde dans les hôpitaux sans rigoler on
pourra faire partir tout le personnel
hospitalier
voilà en vacances qui kiffent un peu il
faut qui kiffent un peu faut qu'il se
repose aussi ils ont connu comme béziers
chaque fois ils ont ils ont ils ont et
traverser la grève parce que la greffe
moi combien je voyais d'infirmières et
de personnels hospitaliers qui allait à
pied à l'hôpital ce qu'ils voulaient
absolument y aller à clinique ou à
l'hôpital et qui j'espère se taper des
journées avec une heure de marche aller
une heure de marche retour maintenant
c'est cette épidémie et c'est vrai que
je dis tous les soirs voilà on est avec
vous à fond merci d'être là merci
beaucoup
voilà et merci parce que au-delà de ça
voilà je sais que j'ai eu des personnes
manquent été hospitalisé voilà dans
divers hôpitaux
le truc c'est que vous gardez le moral
et non seulement vous soigner les
personnes mais en plus vous les aider à
garder le moral et vous avez toujours le
sourire toujours un petit truc toujours
un petit 1
voilà un petit mot pour pour les
remettre parce que vous savez que le
moral des ddd mais des mines de rien des
passions aussi c'est important et je
sais que vous faites beaucoup pour ça
aussi donc merci à vous un petit message
pour vous allez-y allez-y on a un petit
message pour tout le monde
c'est donc avec plaisir oui c'est de
dire 'nous restons travail pour vous
restez chez vous pour nous merci les
chéris ont fait passer le message et
vous avez des raisons restées chez merci
merci d'avoir été là je vous fais de
gros bisous sa bouquinerie la wii du
standard des petits moshi la cadre de
santé de toutes les équipes services et
je voulais bape est licite et l'ensemble
des équipes qui se démène quotidien qui
ont su répondre rapidement de leur temps
familial aussi et puis voilà je sais
merci à elle avait bien raison parce
qu'elles ont fait plein de sacrifices
pour miser des poudriers les gens qui en
ont besoin merci à vous merci beaucoup
et on pense très très fort à vous chaque
seconde voilà sachez le merci merci
d'ailleurs été